Physics is another really powerful tool inside of Unreal Engine.
So what are physics inside of Unreal Engine?
So we can create collisions and responses from a physics model.
You'll see on the screen here you have some form of character mesh and you'll see there's
almost a pinkish-purpleish opaque material around the skeleton.
And that will show where the collisions and responses should be for this particular skeletal mesh.
All skeletal meshes can have these constraints and physics built into them.
So you have components which are constraints.
You can also have vehicles inside of Unreal Engine.
So we can have accurate tire data and wheel blueprints.
You can get the car's feel and exactly how you'd like them to feel.
And also you have a skeletal PHAT, which is just the physics system for skeletal meshes.
Chaos is a big feature of Unreal Engine's physics tools.
And we can do geometry collections.
We can fracture meshes at real time.
You may have seen some demos of real time buildings crumbling from the different demos,
the various demos we've released.
We can cluster objects.
We can connect certain fractures to others.
So there's connection graphs and we can show the knock-on effects of these fractures happening
in real time.
And also you can create fields from these chaos destruction fields.